[Music]
the humans in godzilla vs kong
may not add much in terms of action but
they do provide better dialogue than the
titular monsters
here are the lines in godzilla vs kong
that you never realized were so
important
the first impactful line from godzilla
vs kong isn't even dialogue
it's from the lyrics to the song over
the mountain across the sea by bobby
vinson
the slow soothing doo-wop song plays
over the sight of king kong going about
his morning routine on skull island
the song itself mainly serves to set the
relaxed
tone of the movie's opening scene
however it's also a callback to king
kong's origins
until legendary entertainment started
featuring kong in its burgeoning monster
verse
the character was most famous for king
kong's original 1933 movie and its remix
in most versions of the classic king
kong story kong has a protective
fascination with the american women he
encounters
additionally this sets up two other
elements of the movie
first it references the connection kong
has with jia
the last remaining member of skull
island's kiwi natives
second it foreshadows the idea that kong
may find others of his kind
far away in the bowels of the hollow
earth no matter the context
the song's lyrics are an important
characterization tool
painting kong as a lonely figure and
foreshadowing his desire for a family
later on
things begin picking up when godzilla
destroys the laboratories at apex
cybernetics
seemingly without provocation apex ceo
walt simmons responds by recruiting
hollow earth expert dr nathan lind to
help him access the planet's uncharted
depths
he reveals that the hollow earth
contains an energy source
capable of creating an anti-godzilla
weapon
this is one of the first hints we get at
the true final conflict and godzilla vs
khan
and it is also no coincidence that this
is the same scene in which we are
introduced to apex's chief technology
officer
ren serizawa within the monsterverse ren
is the son of ishiro sirizawa
the monarch scientist portrayed by ken
watanabe in prior films
however that isn't the last of the
serizawas and ren
isn't the only cerezawa in godzilla
history to develop
anti-godzilla technology in the original
1954 godzilla
dr daisuke sirizawa is the scientist
responsible for the creation
of the oxygen destroyer which ultimately
puts an end to godzilla's rampage
in the monster burst the oxygen
destroyer has already been developed by
the u.s government and saw use and
godzilla king of the monsters
the introduction of this new zerazawa
along with the revelation of more
anti-godzilla weaponry
is just another hint pointing towards
apex developing a new way to fight
titans
we need calm the world needs him
early on in the movie we are
reintroduced to madison russell
the daughter of titan experts emma and
mark russell
she drax her friend josh to team up with
anti-apex conspiracy theorist bernie
hayes
who keeps a flask of expensive japanese
whiskey and a gun holster under his
jacket
the three go on to infiltrate and
investigate apex's inner sanctums based
on the idea that the company must be
provoking godzilla
the whiskey comes back into play when it
is revealed that apex
is developing mechagodzilla a robotic
knockoff of the genuine article
after mechagodzilla goes haywire and
begins posing a threat to the human
population
the crew intentionally spills hayes
whiskey
on mechagodzilla's remote computer
system stunning the cybernetic titan
and allowing godzilla and kong to gain
the upper hand in a two-on-one battle
the holster in particular is a
foreshadow to the fact that the whiskey
is actually a chekhov's gun primed to
fire in the third act
and help destroy mechagodzilla the movie
comes to a huge turning point when
madison
josh and bernie break into the deepest
depths of apex's underbelly and discover
the truth about mechagodzilla
using the remains of ghidorah apex has
developed its own synthetic titan
capable of competing with godzilla one
on one the design
utilizes two of ghidorah's three heads
to piggyback
off of their natural telepathic
connection and allow for the presence of
a remote
human pilot in this case ren sirizawa
this is a direct reference to the
version of mechagodzilla present in the
film's
godzilla against mechagodzilla and
godzilla tokyo sos
this mechagodzilla was constructed from
the remains of the original 1954
godzilla
in order to fight off humanity's other
monster threats
much like the ghidorah-based design
featured in godzilla vs kong
this mechagodzilla also went haywire as
a result of possessing leftover
intelligence from its organic structure
shortly after godzilla attacks apex
cybernetics
madison russell visits her father mark
in an attempt to convince him to use his
pull with monarch to investigate apex
madison influenced by hayes podcast
believes that godzilla wouldn't attack
humans without provocation
mark disagrees with her however
believing that even a once protective
monster like godzilla
can go bad and while mark's words
regarding change eventually ring true
they don't come to fruition in the exact
way he describes
after a series of back and forth bouts
godzilla
and kong are forced to set aside their
differences in order to defeat
mechagodzilla
up until this point it seems like the
animosity between the two was
insurmountable
even the vastness of the gap between
hollow earth and the surface
wasn't wide enough for the two to bury
the hatchet but things
change once the two manage to take down
mechagodzilla
after this battle both kong and godzilla
are willing to put aside their
differences and go their separate ways
with one ruling the surface while the
other rules hollow earth
in the end mark was right when he said
creatures can change
the only difference is that this time
they changed for the better
instead of finishing their ancient war
the two bury the hatchet
effectively wrapping up the main
conflict of the series
now that the kings have taken respite in
their respective kingdoms
there's nothing hinting at another
challenger for now it seems
legendary's monsterverse is at peace
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movie moments are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one